et pour en parler on reçoit sur notre
plateau farid deux bars bonjour paris
merci d'être avec nous sur rtl france
vous êtes fondateur du mouvement citoyen
pour l'algérie une journée marquée hier
par le devoir de mémoire est ce qu'elle
a encore une signification particulière
pour de nombreux algériens
cette journée les barricades sachant que
c'était quand même une affaire
interarmées et l'armée coloniale
à cette époque en 1960 voilà c'était
plutôt quelque chose qui qui va dire
qu'il s'inscrit dans l'histoire
coloniale française pas quelque chose
qui résonne véritablement pour la
population algérienne
voilà donc je pense que c'est un devoir
de mémoire surtout du côté français que
du côté algérien alors les
manifestations continuaient malgré
l'élection du nouveau président teboul
le 12 janvier dernier
combien de toi ça peut durer bah ça
durera jusqu'à l'instauration d'un état
de droit en algérie c'est l'objectif une
révolution c'est c'est sa semaine pas
comme ça du jour au lendemain c'est
vraiment du très long terme
une révolution parce que c'est une
révolution ce n'est pas juste un réac
qui veut dire au mouvement en arabe
c'est voilà le les algériens sont
motivés ils savent que la finalité de
tout ça c'est l'instauration d'un état
de droit et une algérie totalement libre
et démocratique
donc tant que ces revendications là ne
sont pas atteintes
les manifestations continueront elles
vous pariez du irak on fêtera les un an
de ce fameux mouvement de contestation
du 20 février prochain un qu'attendent
concrètement les manifestants et
qu'est-ce qui va s'organiser de plus
pour ses 1 an
là ce qui se passait avec l'arrivée 2
imagine t bone à la tête du pouvoir qui
est en fait un représentant de l'armée
un civil qui fait un petit peu tampon
entre le peuple algérien et l'état
majeur sachant que les revendications du
rac n'ont jamais été satisfaites
ça va continuer de bonnes était est un
ancien du système ancien be nice il
était voili enfin bon voilà c'est c'est
le gouvernement qui l'a nommé également
et sont des anciens de bouteflika donc
le système bouteflika est toujours là
c'est un petit peu la feuille de route
du cinquième mandat qui est déroulé et
ça le frac ne l'entend pas et ne veut
surtout pas on va dire relâcher la
pression c'est nécessaire et puis là ce
qui est fâcheux c'est qu'on arrive au un
an du 1er acte mais il y a quand même
une certaine répression qui qui commence
à peser sur sur les manifestants là j'ai
eu des retours au niveau de l'algérie il
ya eu énormément de 2
de représailles et sur les
manifestations sur les manifestants sur
justement s'il ya eu 124 opposant encore
emprisonnés 94 libérés ces dernières
semaines cette répression s'intensifie
en fait de semaine en semaine
absolument et c'est là où justement on
ne comprend pas ce à quoi joue
véritablement président parce que il
souffrait il souffle un peu le chaud et
le froid il avait avant sa désignation à
la tête de l'état un petit peu on va
dire tendu la main en disant que je suis
pour le dialogue etc sachant qu'on ne
peut pas y avoir de dialogue
s'il n'y a pas la libération de tous les
détenus d'opinion ça c'est le béa là et
d'un autre côté il intensifie la
répression et ils enferment de plus en
plus les opposants donc c'est là-dessus
où justement on se dit que le
gouvernement joue le pourrissement il
n'a pas envie on va dire de deux
d'écouter le peuple
absolument c'est ça il n'a pas envie
d'écouter peuple il n'a pas envie
d'aller en direction du peuple
donc c'est s'est battue que le lac doit
ne pas lâcher doit toujours mettre la
pression sur ce gouvernement et ce qui
est un petit peu dommage j'aimerais bien
revenir sur l'arrivée de le drian en
algérie qui régit la mort nous a été
totalement enfin incompréhensible
comment le gouvernement français se
permet-il de donner quitus un
gouvernement qui est un président
totalement rejetée par par le peuple
c'est pas possible est il des droits de
l'homme il est censé écouter la volonté
de deux
de la population à venir comme ça et se
réjouir et sap est totalement le travail
de un nom de manifestants qui justement
en plus de ça c'est des demandes
légitimes
c'est un état de droit c'est de la
liberté contre le musellement de la
presse pour justement les libertés est
ce que ce que ce que prône le la france
au niveau de l'international
donc on a les valeurs de la république
d'un côté et on à du clientélisme de
l'autre ce que fait le drian c'est du
clientélisme il est parti en algérie
tout simplement baladé qu'il est parti
tout de suite après il ya eu une annonce
de te boon sur les gaz de schiste que je
me le dire c'est que ça c'est la venue
de jean yves le drian n'était pas la
bienvenue en algérie absolument pas mais
comment voulez vous que ce soit la
bienvenue à partir du moment où le
peuple ne ne reconnais pas ce
gouvernement
le drian en alors en algérie maroc est
comme qui dirait reconnaît de par sa
venue
ce gouvernement chose que le peuple ne
reconnaît pas et là c'est pas normal
c'est à dire que il se met il en deux
parce ce choix d'aller en algérie et de
rencontrer son homologue il ya d'autres
personnes il
comme qui dirait qu'on fiche à la figure
un an de manifestants mais ça c'est pas
normal surtout que tous ces manifestants
se bat pour la liberté pour un état de
droit
merci beaucoup farid et mais ce débat
d'avoir répondu à toutes mes questions
je rappelle que vous êtes fondateur du
mouvement citoyen pour l'algérie merci à
vous